Loki
l1130 the one that the Loki series
focuses on also known as variant l1130
by the time variant Authority or the TVA
this Loki was created during the events
of Avengers endgame when the Avengers
went back in time to steal the Infinity
Stones from before their destruction by
Thanos alligator Loki was one of the
most surprising and hilarious Loki
variants we saw in the Loki series he
was an alligator with Loki's helmet and
he was apparently a Loki variant that
had been captured by the TVA president
Loki was another Loki variant we saw in
the Loki Series played by Tom Heston
himself he was based on the comic book
story line where Loki ran for president
of the United States in 2162 Frost giant
Loki was a variant that we briefly saw
in the Loki series during a montage of
different lokis being processed by the
TVA he was a Blu skinned red-eyed horn
giant resembling the frost Rance of
yodenheim the race that Loki originally
belonged to before he was adopted by
Odin tour to France Loki was another
Loki variant that we briefly saw in the
Loki series during the same Montage of
different lokis being processed by the
TVA he was a cyclist wearing a yellow
Jersey and implying that he had won the
Tour to France